biden's road to serfdom that's the focus
of tonight's angle
beware those who trash america as
systemically racist and unfair
and then claim to hold the most
benevolent of motives
we cannot have a moral society or a
strong economy when so few
have so much and so many have so little
i'd be delighted to see us move forward
with the wealth tax
at any point america does not suffer
from scarcity
we suffer from greed we can choose
to lift the burden of millions
of people face we can actually invest
in the future of the american people
uh when she says invest
what she means is the government is
going to take money from people who make
money
and spend it on things they believe will
give them more power meaning the
government
now none of these folks the ones you
just heard know the basics of economics
i wouldn't hire them as dog walkers let
alone economic planners
because printing borrowing or seizing
money from income earners
creates neither wealth nor opportunities
for others
but with the woke takeover of our
college campuses and attacks on
all things western i was thinking this
today
it is terrifying to think how little
so many of our college students know
one book that should be required reading
for all freshmen
i'm still using the word freshman by the
way is highest seminal work the road to
freedom
the austrian british economist and
philosopher presented a
stunningly powerful case for capitalism
and a stinging indictment of socialism
writing the power which a multiple
millionaire who
may be my neighbor and perhaps my
employer has over me
is very much less than that which the
smallest functioner possesses
who wields the coercive power of the
state and on whose discretion it depends
whether and how i am to be allowed to
live
or to work beware the bureaucracy
of course the classical liberalism that
hayek was defending
is completely at war with today's
far-left style liberalism
which is better referred to obviously as
illiberal
central planning is at the core of
biden's plans
with the stimulus going far beyond just
cutting checks to individuals
in fact the 1.9 trillion dollars it's
just a down payment on the road toward
european style
socialism a permanent and much larger
welfare state
and an endless supply of low-wage
migrant workers
so when the biden crew tells you that
help has arrived
well it's kind of a half truth and half
lie sure the bill polled well
you take a poll people get money in the
mail but the only thing voters knew for
sure was that they were actually getting
a check who doesn't like that
[Applause]
[Music]
so when we think of help during a crisis
we don't think about needing to pay it
back why should we
but the piper will eventually have to be
paid
there's no such thing as a free lunch or
a free coveted stimulus check
enter the democrats radical wish list
of tax hikes galore now remember the ink
is barely dry in the 2 trillion dollars
and they're already moving on to a
multi-trillion dollar climate change
and infrastructure bill in which they're
going to include
gargantuan tax increases now on the
table
raising corporate taxes from 21 to 28
percent
of course raising capital gains taxes
for many americans raising the estate
tax
raising taxes on millions of small
businesses
but remember they want you to know that
this is
all going to be great for you you're not
going to feel a thing
the president remains committed to his
pledge from the campaign
that nobody making under 400 000
a year will have their taxes increased
his
priority and focus has always been on
people paying their fair share
and also focusing on corporations that
may not be paying their fair share
either middle-class families are paying
more
than their fair share classic left-wing
sleight of hand
are you not sick of the fair share line
every single
american is going to feel the pain of
the tax increase biden is pursuing
he's not robin hood he's robbing you
what do you think is going to happen
when corporate taxes once again get
hiked to 28
do you think that we might lose jobs to
the lower tax countries
here's a list if biden gets his way u.s
companies are going to be
paying more than those in the uk canada
ireland and china so it doesn't take a
nobel prize-winning economist to figure
out that this
is no recipe for bringing jobs back
and investment into the country on the
other hand
this is a great deal for europe and
china
and as businesses flee the u.s of course
what does that mean our economy is going
to shrink
just days ago in fact the wharton school
at u penn updated its analysis of
biden's tax plan
and found that it'll you know retract
the economy through
2050 earnings will also go down
democrats have a lot more tax tricks
though up their sleeves
they're seriously considering a mileage
tax yeah how many miles you drive that's
going to be great for rural and suburban
americans
a gun and ammo tax is being considered
and of course their old stand by the
carbon tax
what i would recommend for the united
states that hopefully we will
in the years ahead go in this direction
is
simply to put in place a carbon tax
putting a price on carbon can be done in
a whole bunch of different ways
i do it on a progressive basis
but perhaps the most insidious aspect of
biden's tax agenda
is his plan to destroy the ability of
many americans
to build intergenerational wealth
because
look when most americans hear estate tax
what do they think
oh that's just for rich people who cares
if their kids get to inherit a lot of
money
well this is wrong on two fronts first
the government has no fundamental right
to regulate who can inherit
the assets or money that you've already
paid taxes on for your entire lifetime
second the victims here aren't who you
think they are
this change would affect families who've
made really smart decisions with small
businesses
farms even buying homes in places like
silver spring maryland maybe in the 90s
or 80s
try to sell a 200 000 house now might be
worth a million dollars
good luck trying to pass that down to
your child by the way this
denies the ability of smart adults to
give
security to their own children and
look i i've been very remiss in not
mentioning the quote wealth tax where
the government
literally just takes a certain
percentage of
our accumulated savings and investments
and just gives them to other people
remember what obama said you didn't
build that
the biden team has reportedly rejected
the wealth tax idea now
but that does not mean congress cannot
put a wealth tax bill on his desk
we've seen how easy it is for the
radicals to drag biden to the left
but ask yourself this when you think
about all the taxes i've just laid out
have democrats really shown the type of
judgment
and wisdom to indicate that they know
how to plan our lives better than we do
as the angle has been warning you for
now almost a year it's hard to believe
democrats are using covid to transform
the economy
so it will no longer be the free market
economy that we created
so many years ago with more prosperity
and happiness than any other economic
system in the world
so the slick pr campaign that they're
unveiling
it's going to promise great changes and
they're going to say they
care but the truth is their policies
never work just take a look at baltimore
or maybe
oakland and you'll see what your future
looks like
and that's the angle